is longer than I thought yeah it did
look shorter
wow I was having a nightmare you were
sleeping
you were talking before was I really
was I saying anything interesting not
really
seriously we're gonna sit in the back uh
yeah that's the safest part of a car in
the event of a crash driver always
protects his side first
so why did you and Karen break up
was it the sex what I can't imagine the
sex being bad about her body you know
what why don't we play that Alphabet
game that you were talking about okay I
will start
um hey
hey my name is Alan and my wife's name
is Alice we live in Alaska and we sell
damn what can we sell
um
doesn't matter I'm trying to think of
what we could sell it doesn't matter
what is that
the air conditioning leaking or
something that doesn't make sense
couldn't be
what is that
Dwight are you peeing
I'm peeing in this empty can oh my God
man that is disgusting twice you said we
couldn't make any more stops I really
had to go hey
get with you man Michael
I think I cut my penis on the lid
oh man slow down we're not going to get
there any faster if we're dead thanks I
know how to drive
oh yeah you really shouldn't glitter
my car my rules
wait what are you drinking I found it
under the seat oh my God Dwight put that
down now give the bottle to Michael
give it to me no just keep your eyes on
the road give me the bottle or your fire
you can't fire me I don't work in this
van give it to me Dwight no give me the
bottle will you stop give it a bottle
please stop just give it Michael stop
give me the bottle
proceed straight
well we're out for six
Last Chance is the Elmhurst Country Club
other side of the lake on the Southeast
side I'll get it I really don't get it I
thought this would work
do everything I had at that guy nothing
that's how it goes sometimes you know
lose everything and everything falls
apart and eventually you die and no one
remembers you that is a very good point
make a right turn
wait wait wait wait no no no it means
Bear right
not there it said right it said take a
right no no no no no no look it it means
go up to the right Bear right over the
bridge and hook up with 307. make a
right maybe it's a shortcut Dwight it's
like go to the right it can't mean that
there's a lightning he knows where it is
going the machine
remain calm I have trained for this
okay
exit the window here we go make a U-turn
if possible
[Music]
are you okay
swim for it
I got you I got you
guys
come on
come on come on
come on
can I turn on the radio no I need
silence or Sam Kennison to prepare but
then you fall asleep and there's nothing
for me to do then listen to your iPod
that's dangerous well then hey you know
what let's just talk
that's okay I can I'm fine I'll just
play a song in my head
let's move
oh you're kidding me
[Music]
does this thing have turbo nitrous hit
the nas Nas
you mean like in Fast and Furious yeah
oh yeah I definitely have not hit the
nas are you sure yes brace yourself
three two go one here we go
this is what a true survivor man does
you simulate a disaster like a plane
wreck you can only wear the clothes that
you have on and you can only use the
stuff that you have in your pockets now
in this case This Disaster is a serial
killer creepy guy who's abducted me and
is taking me out into the Wilderness to
leave me for dead no I would never leave
you for dead you would never Escape well
yes I would and I would survive I would
make sure that you were dead then I
would remove your teeth and cut off your
fingertips you could not be identified
you and they would call me the overkill
killer you
are as creepy as a real serial killer
for real okay what are you doing I am
putting this on so I have no familiarity
with my surroundings
now this way I can't retrace my steps I
don't know what streets movement oh
what are you doing it would be better if
you were unconscious no here God Dwight
stop it stop it stop it do you want to
do this right or not please allow me to
have one cathartic experience in my life
music don't care
come on man just give it a couple days I
think you'll be all right
[Music]
you know what I mean I don't know we
move it away
[Music]
what are we
please don't cry I'm not going to cry I
feel like it but I am not going to why
don't you just take your stupid love
contract and tear it up into a million
it's never a love contract Michael and
besides I've already given a copy to
Dave and it would be just as
embarrassing to get it back from him
because it was handling I want the house
Jan I want the picket fence I want the
ketchup fights and the tickling and the
giggling
I didn't mean it okay I was whatever I
was tired I'm tired and I didn't eat
enough and and that's all that was it
that's it yeah no I didn't so that's all
I'm just saying I didn't mean it
I love you
don't break up you guys
oh you're great together
[Music]
oh it's hard Mike
breakups hurt
we didn't break up
you look like it
sometimes when I'm down like this
helps to sing the blues
okay
no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no that's
really pretty song
that's when you hear me what's getting
you down all right
principles